he likes it he likes
daddy daddy likey I like it you're
listening to the dollop on the all
things comedy Network now this is a
bi-racial american history podcast each
week I hand have a maker of love a stern
dog father Dave Anthony reads a story
from American history to his breath
gareth reynolds who has no idea what the
topic is going to be about can we make a
rule that let's not talk about our sex
lives in the top of the show anymore
let's say that's a thing we did once and
we realized it's not what we want and
that the audience doesn't want that and
i think a lot of people listening got a
really great image you know what I mean
I'm just saying the fact that I'm
letting hand have her go is a testament
to how messed up the second is don't I
yeah some people don't
yeah that's true but again I don't know
I'm just putting it out there that I'm
one of the people with hands I also make
love yeah okay now hit him with the
puppy you both present sick arguments
I said my friend Wow introduction Wow
it's a great song great song nice thing
because we don't normally wear the cans
we don't I can't over the cans some of
the other shooting happening so I'm
gonna make sure we can hear the film
dogs here we live in the world now we
live in a world now where when you say
there's a shooting here we need to say
someone's filming something that's right
so always be specific there we're good
if you would like to watch how dynamic
two guys talking with ear phones on this
time let's not I say it yeah you can go
to the all things comedy YouTube yes and
check out something other stuff there we
got thing called trash tunes where we
watch weird cartoons and there's a bunch
other good content on there so have at
it how about it get get down on it oh
and let me say this I'll be at a cap
city comedy in Austin Texas September
4th through the 7th so that's not this
weekend the following weekend I'll be in
Austin at cap city which is an awesome
Club so come on out you should you
should come out for that I think that's
important yeah if you want to talk about
our our tour dates yes I do obviously
we're gonna be on tour we'll be in in
Europe starting in November we're gonna
be in Stockholm also Amsterdam
Copenhagen Dublin Cardiff Birmingham
London Glasgow a bunch go to doll
podcast home and look for our tour dots
yeah I think that's what it's called and
we got dates here - we'll be in Boise
Madison Sacramento Milwaukee go to doll
podcast calm and there's a little tour
thing going that story thing alright so
I want to talk about something really
quick there's been a lot of a lot of
stuff going on with podcast and the
podcast and sourcing and it's in the
news and stuff so so I think a lot of
podcasters are not familiar with sort of
the rules which I think we are one of
them you know we source everything we
put a link in every every description of
every show to link to
stuff journalists you know would like
more to happen so we're gonna start
following the lead of like what my
favorite murder does and last podcast on
the left so at the end of each episode
I'll read out the sources just to give
props to those guys who are doing a lot
of work yeah because you know there's
there's a there's a legal thing and
there's an ethical thing and and you
know we were told just do this is how
you do it so we're gonna do more yeah
and you'll see those on the iTunes yeah
and I don't wanna upset anybody we're
trying to do the right thing here and
we're trying to we're trying to
everything it's just that you know we're
stumbling along and figuring stuff out
as we go yeah it's it's just you know
that's the way it is yes and I you know
you got it yes I do you do this has got
to be too loud on that note the writer
we based the episode the welfare queen
on has a new book out Josh Levin called
the Queen The Forgotten life behind an
American myth and it's all about that
[ __ ] story and so if you like that
it's supposed to be amazing the
Washington Post
sort of read like a detective story and
it's on all the [ __ ] so supposed to
be [ __ ] great alright yeah
check it out yeah check it out we are
brought to you by herb company yeah
we're as you say in England herb yeah
I've never been able to figure out which
one it actually is in which country well
people will tell you
Lowell Farms is a small california-based
cannabis company that has some of the
best selling cannabis products in the
state with their Lowell smokes a
pre-roll pack with seven hand rolled
half gram smokes sounds good mmm-hmm
Louis devote to high quality some guy
they have a city missed it when I
amazing amazing law has devoted to
high-quality clean and organic cannabis
they have triple lab tested from the
start before it recently became law not
only does low have its own farm but also
partners and employees dozens of farms
up and down the California coast yes
very nice responsibility education is an
important part of the low brand
recreational but responsible and
informed consumption I know the guy who
owns his company one of the owners and
he's a really good guy and I [ __ ]
fully trust them and you gotta you have
to trust where your
pod comes from these yes you just do
yeah the Lola pledge only grow their
flowers with organic fertilizer never
used synthetic pesticides pay our
farmers living wage only use natural
materials from seed to sale that I
recycled and from renewable resources
must be over 21 to purchase for
recreational use Lowell air company man
get on it smoke that ganj bra okay
that's a dress yeah stop
I speak on behalf of the audience
Russell all right can him up can him off
we're also brought to you by quip
world's greatest toothbrush yes I think
it's called hey look the best way to
ease back in here post summer routine
started up before September especially
if you're headed back to school which I
am yeah you are simplify the morning
Doctorate yeah
simplify the morning and evening now
there is simple electric toothbrush from
quip I'm a huge I love I'm clipper I've
had electric teeth it was before
yes names we both had other electric
toothbrushes before the clip and they
don't even compare the clip is the best
its way it's not even it's a superior
brush it's a superior brush it has a
built-in two-minute timer that pulses
every 30 seconds to remind you when to
switch sides and help you clean your
mind cookies and romaine cooks yeah my
oh no watch some of the shows I don't
want to watch yeah yeah mine's a good
hang I've been hanging out with my equip
a lot lately actually so you need that
30 second thing because 90% of us don't
brush for the full two minutes or don't
clean evenly right
I'd be like a 30 minute brush brush have
you actually been told to stop I have
yes by many doctors brush heads are
automatically delivered on a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
for just $5 it's a friendly reminder
when it's time for a refresh and to stay
committed to your own health because 75%
of us apparently use worn-out old
bristles that are ineffective it's in
writing that's weird
they have the kids brush now the new
brush is the same as our original
version just tweaked for size down
mouths kids are inspired to brush better
and often more often with oral care that
looks and feels like the products the
adults in their life use and they're
proud to use quit you know some people
say equip is so good for kid teeth that
the baby teeth don't even fall out
[Music]
yes writers that they're staying in now
yeah so so that's why we left we're big
fans
I thought the sticky things stick on the
mirror yeah you guys have a million
times but I also like to move up down
32nd thing it's all good that's that's
why I love kept and why it's perfect
getting back into a routine quip starts
at just $25 and if you go to get quip
comm slash dollop right now you can get
your refill your first refill pack for
free that's your first refill pack free
at GE tqu IP comm slash dollop boom-boom
we are also brought to you by policy
genius did you know that September is
national life insurance Awareness Month
yes I've been celebrating it for a while
you've been celebrating meaning you're
not having sex during it I'm not having
sex during it most people are not aware
that that's what I'm doing and also most
people aren't aware that September's
national life insurance more right it
doesn't get around as much as a chip now
just talking about it I give out cards
yeah of course in fact most people are
thinking of you
in fact must be alert aware that they
need life insurance at all and that's
why 40% of Americans don't have it if
you have a family it's a really good
thing to have Lord can but look what
getting life insurance doesn't have to
be difficult or expensive right now
prices are the lowest they've been in 20
years in policy genius has made it
easier than ever to get covered so uh
you go online you shop her life
insurance and in minutes you just get
quotes that you compare from top
insurance shares to find the best price
right which is what that's what it
should be yes instead of you having a
guy come over and talk to you once you
plot that happened to me once you apply
the policy Gene's team will handle it
guys soon but thank you man yeah I
didn't like it it will handle all the
paperwork and red tape and policies
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance it's all there it's
all happening
I recommend life insurance I do
especially if you have a family you know
you know why our society doesn't take
care of people so we got to do this Yeah
right if you need life insurance but
yeah and you just haven't gotten around
to a national life insurance awareness
month is a good time as any to get
started go to policy genius.com
get
and in five minutes you do the whole
thing on your phone right now pause the
genius the way to compare and buy the
life insurance
yeah baby go french at the end what's up
you my girl
let's say we're also brought to you by
Squarespace
we obviously enjoy Squarespace
it is the website company yeah and we
use it use it for your personal website
yep I use it for my personal website yep
we use it for the dog sources I use it
for my gear core or hot area that energy
time website yep and and then we also
use it for our just regular dog dog
podcast calm yes so all of them and and
then I use it okay July okay look you
can you continue cool idea into a
website you can check AC work you can
blogger publish content sell products
promote your online business all of it
it's a website you guys now websites
work they got great templates that's why
I got involved in the business over
there the ability to customize look and
feel settings products with more than
just a few clicks nothing to patch your
upgrade ever free and secure hosting
built-in search and you know
optimization it's all there it's all
there
24/7 24/7 award-winning customer service
that's important it's pretty good it's
all the time
so look man if you're ready to start a
business or just start a blog or
whatever it's time let's get it let's
get it destiny calls you yeah
so go to Squarespace calm for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code dollop to save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
domain that Squarespace calm and her
code Dunlop doll doll yeah be clear what
I call it dole washer we're changing the
name of the podcasts oh that's weird
hadn't been discussed oh you know we
should also mention is that we have
another version of this show about the
United Kingdom in England that you can
find it's called whether it was a dollop
England and UK yeah it's a good easy
title people were getting mad and I was
like yes a joke yeah now it has become a
real joke for everybody but yeah we
that's ads that are just about England
it's like a we're gonna do ten or you
know ten maybe eight we're gonna do ten
probably might be episodes
so they don't just come out once in my
Alice's season and then we'll probably
put the live ones up that we record in
England on that feed yeah it's just a
way to have another feed where you know
try to jump into another nation on that
is England a continent I think it's a
comment we're gonna try to jump into the
continent of England it's not by any
means a continent but we should start
around the Bywater correct let's just
comment let's start may 18th 1889 our
time the Thomas Midgley jr. was born in
Beaver Falls Pennsylvania no actually
that's a weird place he falls just
beavers falling oh that's horrible
instead of like the falling rock signs
it's like falling beaver it is
horrifying oh my god hitting the ground
there's thousands of bodies there's beat
dead papers everywhere they never end
oh my god rolling beavers oh I don't
know why people live there
oh the smell horrible
horrifying smell but the dogs love it
the dogs have never been happier his
father worked at a steel production
plant and was an inventor his mother
Hattie sure yeah
was the daughter of an inventor who was
quite wealthy so he came from an
eventing family sure an inventor of an
inventor right yes sure in 1896 they
moved to Columbus Ohio where Tom senior
got a job in wheel and tire
manufacturing okay so they're [ __ ]
killing me yeah sure Thomas graduated
from a Cornell University in 1911 with a
PhD in mechanical engineering okay he
went back to Ohio and started a business
his dad
the Midland tire and rubber company okay
so they're starting they're starting
their own biz sure gonna be [ __ ]
great Thomas got married got a couple of
kids okay and then the business failed
in 1916 you just you just told me that
everything was gonna be okay
so yeah took you down immediately yeah
sometimes it's fast yeah Thomas had a
friend who then hired him as an
assistant
at the Dayton research laboratories here
we go which had just been bought by GM
here we go what no you're starting a
friend okay we've got a we've got a gray
figure in the shadows coming to life
at the lab Thomas worked on problems
facing combustible engines okay because
at that time you know cars are new
uh-huh and to work out the kinks
right people don't like the exploding
car at this time well this is when cars
had this horrible problem called
knocking the engine would make big
knocking noise AHA and clang clang even
the best cars the Cadillacs they make
horrible noises and it's so bad that at
times drivers would think the car was
like breaking apart okay and the noise
happened because gas would mix with air
and then he ignite and explode okay
so they it they and sometimes Jerez get
so freaked out they lose control the car
and crash well that that driver does not
deserve to be put in the category try to
have a big explosion overreacting over
yeah but still yeah I mean I mean it's a
pullover situation it's not oh god the
cliff look Ted what are you doing ah how
did the crashes work huh you know Ted
he's just like oh God oh the cliff oh
there's a cliff now I'm gonna go over it
I should have braids he says all that
yeah he's like yeah you need some well
especially in like the podcast version
of Ted story sure you need to have a lot
of stalkers be a little Newhart has a
radio play
Ted no he's gonna tell you the scene in
the setting and the other characters in
the room and what he's feeling and what
he's physically feeling and doing Oh No
Oh dad we crashed Oh weird we're dying
oh we're dying down here oh we're dying
mommy down there oh yeah sure sir
I better trouble breathing look at my
bowtie
I'm the villain oh maybe we shouldn't do
radio plays oh no it's going great doing
so so they need to stop that explosion
thing they need to put something how
dangerous is the explosion what's not
it's not dangerous it just makes the car
so it's a vanity it slows it down it's
just a problem no it's it's it's
everything slows her down okay yeah so
first he tried a kerosene powered Delco
light engine which was used on farm
equipment nothing tons of knocking
okay then he added iodine to the fuel
sure I was gonna suggest that it worked
but he nude iodine would not work as a
long-term additive gasps - gasps it's
not gonna hang with gas
so we started testing elements similar
to iodide including camphor aluminum
chloride and melted butter well the last
one is so he's out of ideas
he's like sure just throw some butter in
it see what that does I mean I know it's
I just have a lot of butter I mean he's
literally just at home in the morning
putting butter on toast the cars I
buttered the motor I'm a scientist I put
a bunch of butter in the car and I've
ruined it
all right have you slept I have not
slept but I'm all of our dairy products
are now in the car and I put some I put
a bunch of cheese in the tailpipe and
I've just no but I'll tell you what I
just think if we make the car a sandwich
yeah we got a shot okay that's not
I'm gonna go nap and see if that makes
sense in three or four hours yeah well
okay
so he started it so he's testing those
elements this one up for six years he's
just testing different elements for six
years okay quote most of them had no
more effect of been splitting than
spitting in the Great Lakes
I mean butters are crazy well he's
clearly just [ __ ] throwing [ __ ] at
the board right point so he did try [ __ ]
of it he did try [ __ ] okay oh I'm sure
he did the manure doesn't work either
and the smells horrifying people do you
want to go home what's how's your wife
then in December 1921 he tried a tetra
pilot I hope that's how you say te l as
it's known okay let I worked great and
worked great well my problem was it's
less yeah it's there's it's not I say
keep I doesn't say let's go back to the
butter board yeah I liked what we were
doing over there but it was good people
had known lead was poisonous since a
hundred BC so a little while so people
have been kind of on the lead share a
little bit yes so the idea of testing
lead is like all right well I guess this
one's just for you to know if it's
possible to solve because we can't use
it
snick in it well in ancient Rome it was
common knowledge that led it could cause
in insanity and death civil engineer of
Vitruvius 2,000 years ago quote water
conducted through earthen pipes is more
wholesome than that through lead this
may be verified by observing the workers
in lead who are of pallid color so 2,000
years ago it we're pretty hip Tibet led
being bad - it really makes what
happened in Michigan and Flint even more
upsetting that it's been known for that
long yeah I don't I don't want to do a
Flint dalla because I think I'm just
gonna cry
yes like it's oh yeah there's a bad
moment good no those [ __ ] are
in jail no no that they I'm [ __ ]
although did you watch Michael Michael
Moore's movie yeah but when Obama takes
the simple stuff I can't stuff in 1678
workers who made white LED for paint
suffered from quote dizziness in the
head with continuous great pain in the
brows blindness and stupidity okay so
there's a wishing over here now baby oh
man I don't know what's up with that
paint just eating sand I'm eating my
lunch box no don't eat that what the
hell happened otherwise are we paying
these guys I'm a clam okay led miners
would often go mad and even die and
scientists believe low-level long-term
exposure was also bad okay so so we have
lead in the motor that's not great so
tetraethyl lead was first discovered by
a german chemist in 1854 okay but it was
not used commercially because of quote
it's known deadliness sure I think we
are just on the same page we are totally
agreeing that lead is not a good option
a viable path for this let is odorless
colorless and tasteless lead does not
break down over time okay
so we're just talking all downside those
are the best kinds of poisons right the
ones you can never get away
yeah herma poison yeah it does not
vaporize and it never disappears since
there's a lot like the band fish it is
not people gonna be mad right
what fish heads me man I mean I said
that I think it'd be okay
since the 1920s the I don't know what
Maren said on his podcast but he was
just like look guys I don't like Marvel
characters it's dumb like oh geez like
okay Marvel's stupid just get off my
back 101 G tweeted yeah 20 minutes
saying yeah what happened with that oh
god oh god
so since the 1920s led industry have
been fighting bands and even warnings on
paint can labels okay
the lead industry marketed its poison to
children and parents stating that lead
paint was safe and again we've known for
mm just mm yeah this is quite a quite
that's a little bit of time yeah paint
enough for us to be like maybe we were
wrong again
we should probably not use this let's
try it paint ads were printed in The
Saturday Evening Post Good Housekeeping
National Geographic and other magazines
as well as local newspapers Dutch boy
costumes were sent to kids on
Halloween's and they know that's printed
coloring books that showed kids how to
prepare it kids lawyers marketing lead
paint specifically to children yep
okay all right yep yep there's not much
else to say about okay paint you can
drink come on kids come drinking paint
it was marketed as an essential LED was
marketed as an essential to America's
economic growth my god by the 1920s lead
was all over standard middle-class homes
it was in pipes paint telephones ice
boxes vacuums irons washing machines but
dolls toys bag being bags baseballs and
fishing lines but we know that it's bad
yeah we know it's bad so it's come back
but besides oh but because someone owns
it business because you can sell it
right so let's do it right so let's do
it
now and then we'll figure out that later
yeah but scientists were always warning
of the dangers of lead the proof was so
solid scientists we're lucky they hang
around every day just have to be very
frustrated
alright so Thomas Midgley is very aware
of the dangers of that okay as was GM
sure no one knows exactly why the
company decided to push te L that's
tough to hear
instead of ethyl alcohol huh
which also stop engine knocking and is
less of a poison not Pat yes another
poison okay doesn't put his toxic stuff
out into the air now I'm gonna guess
there's a price difference well any
farmer can distill alcohol right okay so
it is anybody just make you can make
right
you can ask for you could solve could
just be done by the people themselves
and there's no real money in that hmm it
all had been around as a fuel for years
the first internal combustion engine in
1826 used alcohol and turpentine before
the Civil War alcohol was the most used
lighting fuel in the country okay
alcohol powered the first engine by the
German inventor Nicholas auto and by
1920 alcohol was a proven automo
automotive fuel great and still what
let's go let Tess in 1906 by the
Department of Agriculture proved its
power and economic benefits in 1907 1908
the US Geological Survey and the Navy
performed 2,000 tests on alcohol and
gasoline engines and they concluded
higher engine compression could be
achieved with alcohol instead of
gasoline oh boy they noted a total
absence of smoke and bad odors and Henry
Ford built his first car to run on farm
alcohol like you the farmer could make
uh-huh in 1929 his model a car had a
knob so you could adjust the carburetor
on gas or alcohol oh my god
it's amazing that I didn't know any like
we just live in such a world that the
propaganda is so massive that nobody
knows that even Thomas Midgley was on
board the alcohol train as I call it in
1921 he like your father
he got off in 1921 II drove a car from
Dayton to Indianapolis with a gas
alcohol blend with 30% alcohol he said
quote alcohol has a tremendous advantage
and tremendous disadvantages including
clean-burning and freedom from any
carbon deposit and tremendously high
compression under which alcohol will
operate without knocking the available
horsepower is much greater than alcohol
with gasoline this is really tough why
is there some yes yes we're living in
the Biff Back to the Future 2 but all
these companies GM specifically wanted
to sell gas oh and ethyl alcohol could
not be patented and just just you needed
while tal could so Midgley suddenly
forgot about the greatness of alcohol
the day today test Diaries of him
testing all those for 16 years have
never been released to the public an
archivist in the GM archive once said
the archives had been quote sanitized
good good good good
well good it start and numbers were all
over the place once Thomas said he
tested 2500 compounds before landing on
TL another time he said 33,000 at that
time he said fourteen thousand nine
hundred ninety one numbers just
yesterday TL became the solution Thomas
and GM went with two stop engine
knocking even though there was a sad
thing yes another thing from brain yeah
even though it was poison in ethanol was
not poison
again that divide is just really hard to
get over
the company chose to kill and harm
people for profit which is we allege
ever I've never heard of that happening
in our capitalism now I am a little like
it is funny
well not funny it's horrifying that uh I
have felt like this has been a problem
for less time than that oh right I mean
oh yeah to hide the fact that they were
using lead which was again poison right
tl was named Ethel that's the wait
what's the other one called Oh God
where is it what does it call I should I
gonna phone right in there Oh ethanol
okay so ethyl and ethanol yeah so they
called it I mean ethanol is still around
we see yeah yes it but it's like I think
it's like five or ten percent in some
places but it's not an ethyl is just tea
yeah yes oh yes they made us similar
yeah yeah oh interesting kind of on that
and you have labeled the poison one
similar to ethanol that's right I called
it just instead ethyl a grandma named
meat ethyl she won't hurt Jesse nice sit
on her lap give her a kiss your brains
gone so they start marketing it there's
no mention of lead in any of the
advertising or reports of course that
there's some say oh yeah I mean have
it's so messed up that they know that
much well don't tell anyone
let's not say let's let's not the wall
room no good Grammy scientists some
scientists were freaked out they pushed
the government to investigate the public
health implications one wrote a letter
to the Public Health Service and asked
them to conduct investigations but the
director responded that would be too
time-consuming and they should just get
the information from the industry yeah
that's true
go that's go go to the company when has
that ever been a problem never know
that's why all those investigations
companies doing themselves always the
own over great company will be like are
you right I was doing bad yeah yeah this
thing I was going to
money on its yeah Thomas told us uh
Thomas mentioned told the Surgeon
General that quote the average street
will probably be so free from lead that
it will be impossible to detect it or
its absorption he's saying that he's
saying so most of the roads are dirt
yeah so he's saying that even with lead
coming out of these exhaust pipes that
it's not gonna go into the ground okay
which is exactly where it will go yeah
well let's just let let's just let that
one fly but he also conceded that quote
no actual experimental data has been
taken so that's zero research get zero
research it's a gut thing I got a
feeling because you don't do any
research into the health consequences of
putting lead in there now
General Motors then funded a government
Bureau to conduct research and added a
clause saying that GM had to approve the
findings it's just very [ __ ] up the
car in oil industry jumped on the Tal
solution for engine knock my god here it
is jim quickly built production
facilities the wonders of what they were
calling ethel were advertised was a big
success to people freaked out by engine
knocking it was the magical product it
was also less expensive than adding
ethanol to gas
uh-huh so did people know to do the
ethanol thing yeah but this is but but
this is it's like it's like they told
women to smoke when their babies you
know what it reminds me of too is the
radium girls yeah totally lick your
brushes ladies lick your brushes yeah in
1922 ethyl gasoline seemed like a wonder
product led was so everyone's just being
told this is it this is the thing that's
gonna it's not hurting you led was less
expensive than I said that that year
Thomas had to turn down speaking
engagements at the American Chemical
Society which he was getting the nickels
medal for invention in 1923 he turned
that down now he wasn't he wasn't going
to speaking engagements he was showing
up yeah cuz he doesn't want to
he probably wants to lie behind closed
doors well lie because he's ill well a
quote after about a year's work in
organic LED I find the my lungs good
Lord wait what
I find that my lungs have been affected
and that it is necessary to drop all
work and get a large supply of fresh air
okay now for the next part of your
sentence he went to Miami to heal no he
went to Miami to heal say more and there
he stayed and healed for a year
okay before he left he assured the
Surgeon General that quote the average
street will probably be free from how do
you do it a dr. Krauss of the Institute
of Technology in Germany said TL was a
quote creeping and malicious poison and
that it had killed a member of his
dissertation committee but Thomas was
undeterred he wrote from Florida to his
boss a GM did they get sell 20% of the
gasoline in the country but it would
actually be more GM had a monopoly with
the patent so the company would make
money for every gallon of gas sold in
April Thomas was made VP in a huge PR
win leaded gasoline was used by the top
three cars at the Indianapolis 500 on
Memorial Day 1923 it's all these people
just standing in the stands just
inhaling lead like it's fine I'm pretty
sure before that all the cars were using
just straight
ethyl alcohol I think that that's what
they were doing they were using ethanol
and yeah I think they were just using
straight up alcohol before that and I
think that's still I might be crazy but
I thought maybe it was just the way one
thing was written but it felt like some
cars still do but I might be totally
right like well it's good that it's but
still it's nice that lead gets a
comeback story yeah
GM signed exclusive contracts for leaded
gasoline with Standard Oil of New Jersey
Standard Oil of Indiana and Gulf oil for
the East Coast Midwest and southern
distribution okay so
in August do pots tal plant in New
Jersey oh good let's get yeah here we go
let's get some more cool people involved
within 30 days a worker died from lead
poisoning oh right okay and DuPont being
rich and having sway over the media was
able to cover it up sure then one of the
first production lines in Ohio was shut
down after two employees died it's fine
it doesn't seem fine it's fine
it seems links with alcohol - no it
isn't you told me the contrary earlier
and another plant in New Jersey there
were more fatalities hey its lead
workers kept hallucinating insects and
the lab was known as quote the house of
butterflies okay so Dave let's come on
but can we be grown-ups for a minute
please what people are tripping their
balls off from your poison so much that
you have a room called the House of
butterfly they're seeing butterflies
they're not there how was work today I
see butterflies what does your husband
do he works on cars and he saw
butterflies yes he yeah then I guess
they have a butterfly room they're all
seeing butterflies yeah they love it
it's great it's great they taught him a
butterfly picture another one of the
earliest factories to take TL was
standard oil facility of Bayway New
Jersey so GM got in touch with the US
Bureau of Mines in September 1923
because no other government agency was
helping and the bureau was as corrupt as
they come the bureau of mines was just
there to promote business if you can
imagine the shocking if you can imagine
in America an agency was still supposed
to oversee something actually being for
business and allowing them to run I can
see it in other countries the bureau
pushed the word for the word lead not to
be used and instead to use well because
it has that nasty poison yes for 2,000
years
yeah because people know poison so if
you tell them that they're probably
gonna be a little hesitant to be like
hey wait a minute that's right isn't
that what makes you go to the butterfly
room in the first year the facility the
first year Bayway new jersey facility
was making tea workers became more and
more fearful of going to work
yes they nicknamed it the loony gas
building oh my god I mean come on how do
you let like how is this possible and
just the fact that people need work so
badly that they do that but I also you
don't need never under like and it's the
same thing now it's just like
numbers-wise just you know you got
numbers yeah these are fat cats they
don't live in clouds they're on earth to
workers at the factory acted
increasingly strange yeah well they're
being poisoned to death
they got Moody it had burst of rage
unable to sleep yes yeah some workers
started getting lost on the plant
grounds and had trouble remembering
their friends oh my god
Larry how do you how do you yeah careful
dad
how how do you like it's the say it is
the same dumb stuff where people just
don't even think about anything with
money because in that you are
compromising your workforce like you're
like you you definitely are going to be
losing stuff as well because you're
losing good workers or skilled workers
expendable but I would also think that
you would if you have people walking
around not knowing where they are you're
like we're paying this guy to not maybe
we shouldn't have a place called the
[ __ ] butterfly room this one's not
the benefit room this one's though no no
yes yes yeah right sorry I get my yeah I
get the leading yes building on the
butterfly room several supervisors
recommend it to the company that the
facility should be shut down interesting
they were freaked out by the way the
creasing by the increasing bizarre baby
you don't need to tell me what they're
freaked out by which they it's always
clearly due to illness yes the company
does not shut down the plant GM pushed
40 L production to be increased right
some people were worried
DuPont chairman irene dupont wrote to GM
that tal quote may be killed by a better
substitute or because of its poisonous
character or because of its destruction
destructive action on the engine
but just a couple months later he wrote
quote I have read the doctor's reports
and I am not disturbed by the severity
of the finding my oh my god something
happened and I don't think it was
reading a doctor's report there you go
he got a report of like how much money
yeah he got a report of a different
nature well that's a lot of money okay
well yeah you're right [ __ ] him no let
people die yeah that's right
on a Thursday a worker at the Standard
Oil beiwei plant in New Jersey named
Ernest Oh Gert started hallucinating
Mobley the next day he was running
around the laboratory screaming in
terror they went home on Saturday he
became so crazy a sister called the
police he was then taken to a hospital
and forcibly restrained and he died the
next day
can we talk about very quickly how that
would probably be very different today
that man would not have died in a
hospital he would have probably died in
jail yeah 100% yeah he totally what it
out of jail it's good point Thanks
I wanna show ya the next week workers in
the loony gas building started
collapsing going to commotions having
fits of violent insanity hallucinations
tremors and babbling deliriously I mean
Jesus Christ what like if you are in
charge at this point you have to be like
alright this is not sustainable well
hopefully they can get a couple shifts
in yeah that's right yeah if you can
train them if you can one of the guys
the boss just puts on a butterfly suit
comes down and it's just like alright
guys so I'm the leader of all of us and
we need you to kind of keep working
through this so trust me my name's Edie
I'm king of the butterflies or queen or
whatever it is because it's full moon
over this way put your hands on the
machines again come on we're good let's
come on move I'll help you move some of
them remember your muscle memory okay
there you go now we're doing it alright
it just goes upstairs and takes off the
butterfly after I did not [ __ ] sign
up for this Jesus Christ
I had to breathe in there
okay so by the end of the week four more
workers from the loony gas building
we're dead 35 were in the hospital thank
God they were a total of 49 workers wow
that's so that's a high percentage yeah
so I would that's like if I'm doing math
I would say almost all almost all your
workers there's like three guys are like
hey what's the plan just Jeff's walking
around I'm fine what's wrong with you
guys
yeah the building man the manager of the
building told the New York Times quote
these men probably went insane because
they work too hard
oh [ __ ] never changes that never changes
he also said the workers had also died
because they worked themselves to death
because of their enthusiasm for the job
this love trying to get it is a little
much this is such a small ask me how
much they love the job how much they
love the job they pretend there are
butterflies there that's not okay how
much that's a side effect of LED no no
yes yes shutting butterflies that guy -
butterfly outfit why is he back here
shut that door this is when the
government decided to release that
report on the research hey that's fun
GM funded with the agreement it had to
approve the findings oh right okay over
that ya know this is it came out right
as the media is going crazy over what
was happening at the loony gas nose
ladders good for you the state of New
Jersey was not impressed with the
explanation they got shared on the plant
and order the plant closed the local
district attorney called the chief
medical examiner from New York City and
asked if his chemistry division could do
some research and at eeo the minute the
medical examiner was on we don't need to
do reasonably you know the answer with
what it's LED date no okay so I'm a
medical examiner you're a guy who come
to me say they were seeing butterflies
they've been seeing butterflies it's
like it's [ __ ] LED we're trying to
figure out what it is it's they're
seeing butterflies they're calling the
building loony they're having me
tell you the problem these guys are
dying and not coming to work now my
question is what can we do to fix that
yeah so not used the lead the lead part
we're not using lead we're using tal
okay break the Elle's for it stands for
let well let's now we're using so anyway
we've moved on from that one outside of
that what can we do to stop these guys
from dying from butterfly overdosing
yeah I feel like we got we got our wires
crossed it's not butterfly overdosing
they're dying from lead to led the human
why are the butterflies killing my
workers who do they work for
that's my question do you think they're
in the departing ok yeah who are they
working for yeah they are there yeah
well so we got to stop the butterflies
you know it'll kill a butterfly what go
ahead
god damn it yeah let's bad for
butterflies humans it's fine for now we
used a lot of it here actually it's been
killing some of our guys but the
butterflies have all right Africa we
were talking about yeah
smells like let in here again the
medical examiner's already on record as
having said quote the fact that it is
readily absorbed in highly poisonous was
discovered in Germany about in about
1854 when TL was discovered and it has
not been used in the industry during
most of its 70 years since then because
of its known deadly this is the place
right yeah deadliness yeah it's a thing
that this poison he said that was well
known for damaging nervous systems and
led vapours that were released in TL
manufacturing were absorbed through the
skin and inhaled into the lungs New York
had the best forensic techs toxicology
department in the country and the chief
chemist was known as a tenacious
researcher so for three weeks
he learned to figure out how much TL the
workers absorbed before they became ill
crazier dead he compared the first four
dead to the last guy who died who had
gone out screaming in a straitjacket
like I mean that's the way to go yeah it
was a lot of ways to go but screaming in
a straitjacket like you're going out
yeah yeah yeah yeah again yep big finish
big vacation coming up he found the TL
con he found that TL concentrated in the
lungs of the brain in the bones it was
clear the lead vapor had been inhaled
and later it would be discovered masks
used at the plant did not fill
throughout
the lead in the TLB we're actually
putting lead in the mask to kind of
block the lead fumes we've got a liner
of lead in there and that word eyes are
able to really painting the inside with
the Dutch boy paint which is great paint
it's for kids can drink it I know if you
heard the new add kids elite it use it
for spaghetti sauce it's Dutch boy paint
so yeah your kids can use it spaghetti
sauce now and if it made any direct
contact with skin it was absorbed
alarmingly fast so essentially our
research has told us that lead is bad
still yeah I'm not getting much yeah
that's a lot of what I'm picking up for
there Standard Oil decided to fight back
and hold the press conference at its
Manhattan offices the war our lad must
stop the press conference featured one
Thomas Midgley who had come back oh good
alright the comeback kid he told
reporters that if Ethel was handled
properly there was nothing dangerous
about it as in not putting it in cars
exactly oops I'm sorry I'm rusty that's
a little Ari I've been I've been fooling
I haven't haven't lied for a year sorry
Tom especially then washed his hands in
a bowl filled with te l quote I'm taking
no chances whatever nor would I take any
chances by doing that every day who does
that remind you of oh yeah Obama yes
went when Obama drinks the Obama drinks
very in a very stage staged event really
upsetting pretends off-the-cuff to just
drink some random tap water yeah and
it's all very fake and as we know
as we know that story does not have a
happy ending or an ending yet sorry my
do we have a nanny situation okay so
naturally Thomas blamed the workers at
the different plans
sure for not protecting themselves
properly right because they're
independent contractors that's right
right gloves and masks were readily
available and it was the workers
responsibility to wear them even though
we just learned previously that the mass
weren't effective right a VP explained
that the workers weren't well educated
men and maybe they didn't realize
working with tal was quote man's work
here's the thing what's happening what
it's man's work dude and they're and
they're like dying like ladies I just
could I mean that it's good times dude
it just it is good times yeah America
has never been better
Thomas was asked about what kind of
research had been done about the health
effects of TL and he gave the same
answer as he had two years before none
we didn't do that why would we do that
it's great it's led what's gonna go
wrong
yeah almost all research was focused on
improving the Tal formulas not whether
or not he'll kill you right make you see
butterflies and again he then rubbed
tiel's on his hands the show wasn't
dangerous closes I'm not taking any
chance whatever nor would I take any
chance doing that every day then the New
York world said Thomas frequently bathed
in tea okay so a couple things no he
didn't
no he doesn't that thing he's putting
his hands in probably not tal
right I don't think it was yeah I don't
think he would ever do it especially not
after he just came back from a year of
almost [ __ ] dying or whatever was
happening now but reporters learned
employees were calling it the loony gas
building and doctors told the press that
the violent insanity was quote brought
on by the gradual infiltration of lead
into their systems all right well we're
gonna talk to some non doctors and get
their opinion you guys seem pretty
closed off to options Jimmy on the plant
what do you think happened oh it's
pretty obvious whatever here buzz
they're all doing cocaine yeah yeah just
a bunch of him vagrants anyway
Beck I'm dating that butterfly I should
go over there the New York Medical
Examiner released his report the New
York City then banned the sale of Te
Anau come on and the sale of quote any
preparation containing lead or other
deleterious substances and I listed
patella Connie what that works sure as
an additive to gasoline okay so New York
gets it
so did New Jersey the state so it
Philadelphia so did Pittsburgh seems
like a East Coast thing yeah the Bureau
of Mines released report saying ethyl
was not an issue of course yeah clean
lead the Newark Times front page
headline was quote no peril to public
scene in Ethel gasps a bureau of mine
reports after long experiments with
motor exhausts more deaths unlikely
that's the end of that chapter is the
bureau miser it was a growing pain that
they went to because yeah yeah totally
crop yeah yeah yeah it's like that a
great NRA story my background checks
will increase shooting that's right yeah
still the company's agreed to stop
making tl until they got a clean bill of
health to move forward because they're
getting so much [ __ ] cities are shutting
down a grand jury then acquitted
standard oil of any responsibilities in
the workers illnesses and deaths hmm
what if this was even though a report
stated the deaths were due to poisoning
and that the company should start making
tl again could not should not start
making to you again until the
who is sure workers were saying it was
the other lawyer well that's pretty
damning but uh who likes pie I mean
there's no way they can just pay the
jury oh yeah that sounds there sounds
tough sounds pretty damn it ladies and
gentlemen of the jury sure this document
says that lead is the cause of all these
things but have you ever seen a man
shake his keys look at that that crazy
look at him Django
makes you forget about everything else
you heard in the courtroom today huh
innocent know what hold on let's get
that let's get that right now let's do
this now let's close up I rest yeah yeah
that's probably what they did they
probably like let it out the jury they
probably made the jury breathe let their
drink this okay we find the defendant
Spacey sorry
wanna play we're gonna ride the
butterfly Thomas Midgley kept with the
company line telling a group of
scientists quote so far as science knows
at the present time
tl is the only material available which
can bring about these anti-knock results
except for the other things that I
discovered along the way that I'm lying
about which are vital importance to the
continued economic use by the general
public of all automotive equipment and
unless a grave and inescapable hazard
rests in the manufacture of t/l
it's management cannot be justified okay
look a lot of you are worried about te L
and what it does now I'm putting my
hands in it to show you but now I'm
gonna have a little sip see poop wasn't
good to you right law and now to show
all the naysayers I'm gonna butt chug a
little bit so we've got a funnel here
and my buddy Hank here he's gonna pour a
bunch of t/l into me
what is the Mothman doing here that
heats my agent he's really good he's a
closer
I'm a 1925 the US Surgeon General called
a national tetraethyl lead conference to
be followed by the formation of an
investigative task force to study the
problem hey you know it's amazing it's
how we already know that leg is a poison
so let's take it through the corporate
slow red tape grind for a few years
that same year Midgley published his
first health analysis of Tia which
acknowledges
minor health risk quote compared with
other chemical industries it is neither
grave nor inescapable and obviously I
couldn't write the book my hands fell
off a year and a half ago I was putting
him in never mind so the government then
held the Tal conference in DC in May
1925 which would be followed by the task
force to say the issue this was the
brainchild of now the TL company's GM
DuPont etc people from both sides the
debate were there but more on the pro
side one was Frank Howard who was a vice
president of the ethyl corporation he
made what did he think he made the
argument that leaded gas was a quote
gift from God
yep there we go there it is lovely
lovely lovely well if he wanted us to
have it by the way all these gifts from
God's these are the same people who
fought weed legalization forever we got
all these bountiful gifts from God
Colette marijuana is a sin don't burn it
you know what God wants us to have death
air let me ask you this
when you smoke a joint do you go to
butterflies ville yeah sometimes oh well
I still can't smoke it buy this drink
this put your hands on it he also said
it quote continued development of motor
fuels is essential in our civilization I
made my daughter Ethel that year table
SH Tomas Authority said that the task
force was made up of industry scientists
like Thomas Midgley great so that's good
that he's evaluating this there were no
experts from any of the cities where
Thiele been banned interesting or any
agency that produced a critical analysis
of t/l interesting well I think I
let's all be patient and they come back
because I have a pretty good feeling so
word leak that another 8 TL deaths had
happened and more than 300 injuries had
occurred at du Pont's deep water plant
sure
I think Delaware yeah yeah just because
the problem is still totally there no
it's fine right ok
didn't matter in January 1926 the task
force released its report it concluded
there was quote no danger posed by
adding tald gas quote no reason to
prohibit the sale of leaded gasoline as
long as workers were well protected
during the main you
process there's but one downside men's
dicks get a lot bigger so that's the
only thing yeah they become better at
that but yeah outside of that there's
nothing so they learn how to use them
better yeah yeah yeah I know they're
better lovers in general but if you guys
aren't into that then you know just
figure out you don't want good-good
lovemaking for men that's fine no it's
fine so at that point lead was pretty
much here to stay I mean a lot of other
stuff happened but led was in well we
had a task force yeah who overturned the
reality of lead so Midgley was then
reassigned to the subsidiary company
Frigidaire well they want to make people
diet the fridge
will you help Tom how can we kill more
people refrigerators well I think we
make a freezer out of lead and we make a
lot of these areas out of lead and
instead of a butter area it's a lead
zone they want him to find a substitute
refrigerant for cooling systems okay at
the time refrigerators and air
conditioners used coolants that were
highly unstable chemical vapors that
occasionally caught on fire okay let's
go that's not good for a veteran that's
not good I could catch on fires let's
kill the people at the fridge
refrigeration systems killed a handful
of people here okay so let's get that
number way up that's a low number so
what can we get that into the millions
is that do you think that's doable is
that just the kind of a dream in 1928
Midgley and his team developed the
world's first chlorofluorocarbon CBC a
stable mix of chlorine fluorine and
carbon it was marketed under the trade
name freon okay it was a non-toxic and
non-flammable so leaks couldn't kill you
or and the refrigerant explode Dave
which is great we don't want forgeries
explode Dave it's time for you to be
positive Dave I'm worried that this man
has looked in the face of a good
solution before and walked away I'm a
little nervous
hmm also freon was non-toxic none
non-flower lot of great things he held a
press conference I've discovered he took
a mouthful of freon and blew out a
candle okay this guy needs to just start
actually feeling like people believe his
opinion or so I don't know what's gonna
he's lie like this'll it's not waters if
you
a lot you're lying on this left like
it's it's a level it's it's thou dost
protest too much
okay uh he also dropped a little gas all
right and now to drink it and put a lit
match in my mouth while I also put my
head inside of a lion's mouth huh you
guys think of this I'm not sure what
these things are anymore but I'm a bit
of a showman I'm really I'm really
feeling myself here
The Morning Call wrote Thomas said quote
the fumes in large quantity produce a
queer intoxication accompanied by a soz
modak jerking of the muscles so I'll
bring up in the case of animals to
tested he said his rapid a dog
staggering from the fumes sobered up in
less than a minute monkeys and dogs
breathing the stuff 7 or 8 hours daily
for weeks developed some resistance some
resistance to the drunken effects
I just so there's a free dog party on
it's terrible for the monkey ever done
always in session they ever done
whip-its it's kind of the dogs are doing
eight hours I've never net eight hours
of booklets I'll say that it's great no
I bet I bet it really loses its charm
free I began to be putting air
conditioners and was soon the
refrigerant of choice but 1950 more than
80 percent of American homes had a
refrigerator bran was beginning to be
used as a propellant in aerosol cans it
seemed like a godsend
freon though was bad okay when thorough
fluorocarbon gets into the atmosphere it
is hit with ultraviolet rays and it goes
through a series of chemical reactions
that breaks CVC's down to a chlorine
atom a chlorine atom then reacts with an
ozone molecule and breaks a zone apart
and destroys it so is so the chlorine
atom can also repeat this process it
doesn't break down a single CVC molecule
can destroy a hundred thousand ozone
molecules okay so essentially you are
now just making chlorine fridges I mean
it's not the fridges in chlorine it's
when it gets into the air sure but
you're essentially not great making like
chlorine vapors well you're making your
period here your your
you're able to keep your meat cold for a
longer time also also saunas gonna kill
you also nature's decided to have a
little fun with what your system is
turns out there's an ozone layer
surrounding the planet that protects us
from harmful rays well I really can
Thomas probably didn't know this because
he had no formal training training in
chemistry he's just a mechanical
engineer but he ate a fridge at one
dress conferences yeah I was out ate
this fridge it's good for you Thomas
received many awards including the
Priestley medal the highest honor given
by the American Chemical Society he was
given two honorary degrees he was
elected chairman of the US National
Academy of Sciences oh my god during
World War two
Thomas served as head of one branch of
the National Defense Research Committee
he conducted extensive research to
develop new synthetic rubbers but then I
got polio during the war mmm he was left
unable to use his legs and was in
constant need of help okay his final
invention was a system of pulleys and
ropes that helped him to get in and out
of bed okay
and I'm November 2nd 1944 he died of
asphyxiation after his own invention
strangled him to death
oh my came just angled around his neck
what died at 55 what the [ __ ] the dude
three-stooged my
he three-stooged himself to death that
when that goes wrong when you're like
it's perfect I'm getting in and out but
when you're like caught in here no no
this is theirs this will look really bad
yeah so 55 years old at the time his
death he was considered one of the
nation's most prominent he did die doing
what he loved he did lying he was one of
the prominent scientists in the country
when he died he couldn't have known the
effect freon
would have on the atmosphere but he
certainly knew the effects of lead
obviously lead was phased out of
gasoline beating in 1975 and was pretty
much out of the market by 1986 but it
was not eliminated because of its
toxicity it was remove from gasoline
because it messed up catalytic
converters it's bad business we'll have
to recall some cars and then they they
just study so it's a study that is like
it's hard it's not a study that you can
say that's absolutely it's one of those
so violence was terrible
mm-hmm and then as Alice was you know
taken out they went down violence went
on traumatically so the violence in the
70s and insane compared to like the 90s
right that's we're just in all of
society we're getting back yeah
in 1973 CBC's were detected in the
atmosphere and in 1984 scientists
discovered a recurring springtime
Antarctic ozone hole the Montreal
Protocol was signed as does that feel
like an adorable problem we work hard
now right remember we were just like
there's a hole in the ozone I mean
people were totally freaked out about it
I remember but then also three years
later everyone got together and signed a
thing to get rid of it there okay let's
stop stop doing that yeah there was like
yeah that's a good idea
yeah dupont agreed to reduce and
eliminate cbc production so in this case
dupont which is a really horrible
company still better than the koch
brothers right the in Exxon and she'll
on all the ones that knew exactly what
was he P starting the seventies the
worldwide production of CBC's was
totally phased out by 2005 although
three factories in China were just
recently discovered it was like pouring
out of their factories the CDC and the
Department Health and Human Services
have reported blood lead levels in
Americans aged one year to 74 years had
declined 78% 78 percent between 1978 and
1991 when they did study in like 1930
the amount of lead in the dirt on
streets had gone up 50% well what is so
shady and shitty about the way that
companies can poison people is that you
don't and they're and even when there is
the you know there are like specific
evidences evidence of like like in the
the Gulf spill and stuff like people
having allergic reactions like her exit
or the water and stuff so there are
there are direct
correlations but then there's also these
ones where it's just like yeah what does
put polluting the environment put it
having plastic and things that we're now
eating what are the cumulative effects
of these that are not gonna be something
where someone's gonna go
oh it's literally because of this and
this person lied about it it's just like
oh yeah we just have this stuff in the
earth now maybe I don't know do we live
cancer oh wow what's it from I don't
know
hey is it good that it's raining small
plastic fibers and is that Colorado is
that okay is that good it's bad so in
this in this case the the planet got
together to stop the ozone hole so TL
continues to be used as of 1996 93% of
all gasoline sold in Africa contain land
94% in the Middle East 30% in Asia 35%
in Latin America 1.7 billion people
living in developing nations are in
danger of lead poisoning 90% of which is
attributed to leaded gasoline so I mean
it's like [ __ ] DDT you know they love
hearing that still kept sending another
where else or you know all that [ __ ] but
yeah like when we when we decide in
America to stop using covering the
companies still make it and they [ __ ]
send it to poor countries like you know
it's why you need a worldwide socialist
movement yeah yeah well the thing that I
the thing that I was reading about
earlier is the way that companies are
like they're going to make protesting
illegal well they already are it comes
yeah and then it's already starting
texas in other places you can't protest
against pipelines
you cannot protest against the fossil
fuel industry and so that is its again
it's i mean we talked about it it's like
it never the stuff that if you want to
get your information from the news you
can't really be watching the person
talking on the news you got to watch the
ticker the ticker has all the stuff that
in 10 years is the bad stuff yeah it's
just little stuff where it's just like
oh they got rid of this regulation or
they put this person here or you know
it's just slowly the erosion of the line
between oversight versus the
monopolies that are making all the money
and the more that that line of roads and
goes away it's like a joke now I mean
when you have Rex Tillerson in charge
say it being the Secretary of State I
mean it's just like he literally should
be in The Hague well I mean it is just
like the you know there is no oversight
to this anymore and that's why you know
I think there are a lot of positive
signs when it comes to how people are
fighting climate change but this is a
thing where it's like the people in
charge who actually make decisions have
to be the people who are also part of
the movement and I'm fighting it yeah
because otherwise you're gonna get
people who like we have now we just
asides a DNC both sides I did not hold
siding deciding to shut it down as they
are making the elites and they are
making money and they don't give a [ __ ]
about what party you vote for they just
want to keep making their money yeah
they really do so the main sources for
this what the secret history of led by
Jaime Lincoln kipman on the nation which
is a really long [ __ ] really long
sort of just building yeah article about
led Debra bombs two-part series at the
door of the leading gas building in
wired also the BBC City lab calm and the
lactic why it took decades of letting
parents before we banned lead and again
Flint we're actively deciding to put
lead pipes in in pay so and it's not
just Flint no it's happening all that
well let's stories all over the country
it's just [ __ ] poor people and the
more that this stuff happens the more
that that water or water that we all
don't give a [ __ ] about is gonna get
into our water and then we'll be like oh
[ __ ]
we should have cared about the poor
water yeah okay well I'll be at the bar
tonight through tomorrow morning
drinking away this episode this is
probably the number one requested
episode oh that's good Thomas Midgley
that's something good yeah it was good
he just probably killed thousands and
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people yeah and I will say the slight
trade-off for having a man
died from pulleys it's pretty great men
gotcha
we sign police